c'était une grande première le centre
commercial parly ii a ouvert ses portes
à trois lycées blinois ce jeudi 29 mars
après une introduction théorique d'une
heure les 60 étudiants ont pu découvrir
les espaces du site avec comme guide le
directeur du centre
le nôtre est là depuis 1969 les
boucheries nivernaise pareil sachez que
les boucheries nivernaise fournissant
viande le palais de l'elysée quand même
voilà donc on a les traits très belles
maisons une opportunité pour les
étudiants de première et de seconde
destinée à une voie professionnelle dans
le commerce
j'ai trouvé cette journée très
enrichissante très bien et puis j'ai pu
découvrir différentes choses à prendre
le monde du travail
connaître plus le centre commercial
impressionné par la pertinence des
questions sur le nombre des visiteurs
les loyers l'activité les travaux le
fonctionnement du centre de sécurité
vigipirate
jet tours ou très intéressés très
avertis sur le suggérer la visite a
également permis de présenter les
différents secteurs et métiers du centre
qui compte 2200 emplois objectif
susciter des vocations
je pense qu'à cet âge là on est en
recherche un petit peu sur des on
apprend vraiment une intuition sur
certains secteurs d'activité ou métier
qui pourrait plaire là l'avantagé cette
démarche encore entendu vraiment du
concret alors le marketing à paris deux
c'est de l'affichage urbain de la presse
de la radio avoir un message différent
de celui de la concurrence donc c'est ça
rend les choses plus concrètes et je
pense que ça peut un petit peu aidé un
jeune dans son questionnement et son
choix de carrière
après une première édition réussie le
centre commercial devrait renouveler
l'expérience l'année prochaine avec
d'autres lycées du secteur